I lost my sight for progressively over
time my photoreceptor cells of my retina
kind of cease to function and die so if
you picture like a Jumbotron screen at
an arena and imagine the bulbs on that
screen kind of slowly and randomly break
over time that's that's what happened to
me so you know at first it's you know
maybe you don't even notice it then
maybe it's a little knowing eventually
you have some some issues sort of making
out the image for me sight became this
sort of bizarre experience where objects
would you know appear and then morph
into other objects and disappear kind of
depending on what information I had or
you know how what kind of clues I had it
was just sort of this conscious arduous
process to see what was amazing is
giving that experience I literally saw
firsthand how powerful our minds are to
create the reality we experience to
create this immersive experience of
sight for example which I always thought
was you know objective and true and not
much to it but I saw that that's not the
case at all right sight is this unique
personal virtual experience that our
minds create so that was the sort of
profound insight for me in terms of how
I went blind that was then really a gift
in my life in many other ways because I
realized that all of us really shape our
reality shape our experience of the
world in all sorts of ways that we're
not necessarily so aware of for me
recognizing this this power our ultimate
down understanding and embracing it
Canadian to it 1000% is an endless
source of hope and optimism your life is
not happening to you you are creating it
and that's liberating it's yours to make
of it what you want well much of life is
it requires a tremendous amount of
effort and scale
and discipline so you know merely
believing or wanting something for
yourself doesn't doesn't mean you're
going to make it happen for yourself you
actually have to put the put the hard
work in right and make it happen so we
all confront circumstances in our lives
that are that are unfortunate setbacks
failures end of a relationship loss of a
career etc etc now unfortunately we
would very often criticize ourselves and
kind of beat ourselves up or for those
failures or setbacks which there's
there's no no good in that the key is
what do we do with those circumstances
what how do they manifest themselves in
our lives what do we make of them to my
mind that's really about introspection
on how you want to internalize the
circumstances you find yourself in in a
given moment and with awareness you can
then take control and really work to
create the the life the reality that you
want yourself
[Music]